[Music]
I don't think I've seen a movie like
Coco where people were so ready to
declare it a Disney classic the second
it came out since probably frozen
critics loved it people loved it adults
love - kids loved it and yeah I have to
agree I'm on the same boat Coco is not
only visually amazing but it's great
with its characters it's phenomenal with
its music its colors are unbelievable
the imagination is fantastic it's funny
it's heartfelt you'll laugh you'll cry
it's kind of everything you want out of
a movie which is funny because the setup
for this film I usually hate Miguel a
young boy in Mexico loves playing the
guitar and absolutely adores music but
his family tell me if you've heard this
one before doesn't like music because
something happened in the past that
makes them suddenly hate all music so
it's forbidden but that can't stop
Miguel from wanting to pursue it Christ
I hate these kind of stories I hate them
to my core I hate them because you know
music isn't bad you know the people that
forbid it are gonna come around and
that's most of the focus just someone
trying to live their art and somebody
else being a jerk until the very end
thank heavenly God though that's not
what this movie is focused on it's
actually more of a side thing you see
Miguel has this fascination with his
great-great-grandfather who abandoned
his great great grandmother even leaving
behind a three-year-old daughter
Coco Coco doesn't remember much and
doesn't even process much she doesn't
even always know who Miguel is but
nevertheless they get along very well
and Miguel oh we stressed to figure out
more about his great-great-grandfather
who was a famous musician when the Day
of the Dead comes however he steals his
great-great grandfather's guitar and
that sends him all the way into the land
of the dead
this world is amazing it looks so grand
so gigantic so colorful you practically
want to live there or die there you know
what I mean he comes across a bumbling
Skelton named Hector and the two of them
have to juggle well surprisingly a lot
in the story as they have to get the
family's respect they have to get back
to the land of the living looking Hector
to the land of the dead tried to find
Hector's great-great grandfather while
also unraveling this mystery while also
trying to stop people from forgetting
who they are because once somebody
forgets who they are then they disappear
altogether
surprisingly kind of complicated which
makes it all the more interesting that I
actually followed all of it and
apparently a lot of kids seem to follow
it too
the film is very good at holding your
hand when it needs to hold your hand and
letting it go when it needs to let it go
this plot could have so easily been too
complicated but I was amazed at how well
I could follow along this is also one of
the few recent Disney stories that has a
surprise villain but it works the setup
isn't just a go gotcha it's to actually
set up a connection between some of the
other characters and it works into what
they were setting up before and it
furthers what's coming up next
a surprise villain can be fine but it
has to work into the story and that's
exactly what this one does the
characters are also likable even the
ones that forbid music are still very
likeable they're so energetic yet they
all move differently in the different
facial expressions and the different
energies that they all have is just so
great to watch in most Disney movies I
can think of a comic relief that I don't
like or a side character that gets too
much attention but here everyone feels
like they get just the right amount of
screen time to be really enjoyable it's
funny because everyone says they get
teary eyed at the end of this movie and
I get teary eyed too but not at the
scene you're thinking for me it's early
on when Miguel just likes hanging with
cocoa and cocoa half the time doesn't
even know who he is but she just looks
so happy and content and comfortable
being around him and he knows she
doesn't know who he is but he still
wants to entertain her nonetheless cuz
he's just such a likeable character and
oh my god this gets me every time it's
just so sweet and it melts my heart I
guess if I really had to nitpick the
only scene I felt was a little pointless
is where Miguel is performing in front
of all these other dead people it's not
a bad scene I just didn't entirely see
the point of it it didn't seem to
connect to the rest of the story where
everything else really connects to the
story maybe it was just an excuse to
have another song which in a movie like
this I can kind of see why the music is
a big part of it the song that
eventually won an Oscar remember me is
so good because they played in so many
different ways early on is played as
this big show number this big gigantic
thing where there's like dancing women
and fancy costumes and loud instruments
but then it can also be played as such
as
slow soft thoughtful song and that's
really where it shines and that's what
was meant to be it's so clever how this
movie shows the different ways you can
look at music like the different ways
you can look at people or life or death
it's just odd damn it it's so good now I
feel like it wouldn't be doing my job if
I didn't bring up a film that was rather
similar called book of life this came
out before Coko and it also has to deal
a lot with music and Day of the Dead and
this bright colourful world honestly
when I saw Coco the first thing that
popped in my head is that this was gonna
be a ripoff but at the same time I had
to remind myself it's kind of like
seeing Santa Claus in a different
Christmas movie this is just kind of the
day they the dead does have a very
distinct look and both these movies do
pick up on it and in comparing the two
Coco is by far the better movie but no
is a lot taken from this were they kind
of looking at each other the same way
ants and bug's life was kind of keeping
tabs on one another I feel like for all
of you Raja Nellie that's in this movie
I have to bring up a film that does have
a similar visual style and ideas
nevertheless Coco still feels like its
own thing visually it's amazing
musically it's amazing the characters
are amazing the animation the colors
it's all amazing based on its
description from the plot and forbidding
music and the surprise villain I would
think I would hate this film but much
like the movie teaches it's all about a
different point of view and the point of
view this movie has I know I'm gonna be
watching a whole lot more in the future
[Music]